voter fraud is a really ineffective and
inefficient way to try to win an
election because the number of
fraudulent votes
is almost always too small to actually
impact the outcome and the risk of
getting caught for voter fraud is high
now Republicans will say everybody's
getting away with voter fraud all these
Democrats are getting away with it the
truth is
there's no reason to believe that that's
the case and we've seen the Brennan
Center for justice study the numbers the
penalties for being caught are severe it
is a really bad political strategy It's
relatively easily detected and it would
be better for these people to spend
their energy on activating voters help
make the case that voters should vote
for a candidate because they think that
that candidate would actually do good
things for them I know it's like a crazy
thing to think about but that would be a
much better way to spend your time and
the last element of this is
when people get caught
it's almost always Republican